Ce soir je voudrais commencer par quelque chose de complètement différent,
je vous demande de quitter la terre avec moi
et de sauter en haute mer pour un instant.
90 pour cent de l'espace vital de notre planète est en haute mer,
et c'est là que la vie, titre de notre séminaire ce soir, a commencé.
C'est un endroit vivant et magnifique,
or on est en train de changer les océans
pas seulement avec l'excès de pêche, ou la pêche irresponsable,
ou avec des polluants tels que les fertilisants de nos cultures.
Mais aussi, plus récemment, avec le changement climatique,
et je suis sûre que Steve Schneider, vous donnera plus de détails sur cela.
Alors que nous continuons à bricoler avec les océans,
de plus en plus de rapports prévoient que le genre de mers qu'on est en train de créer
sera favorable à un type d'animaux avec peu d'énergie comme les méduses et les bactéries.
Et ça c'est le genre de mer qui nous attends.
Les méduses sont des êtres étrangement hypnotiques et beaux,
et vous verrez des exemplaires magnifiques dans l'aquarium vendredi,
mais ils piquent et les sushi et les sashimi de méduse
ne vont certainement pas vous rassasier.
Environ 100 grammes de méduse font quatre calories.
Alors, c'est peut être bien pour garder la ligne,
mais vous ne tiendrez pas longtemps avec.
Une mer qui n'a que des méduses en abondance
ce n' est pas très positif pour toutes les autres créatures qui vivent dans l'océan,
à moins que vous mangiez de la méduse.
Voilà ce prédateur vorace en train de lancer une attaque furtive
contre cette pauvre méduse qui ne se doute de rien, une vélelle.
Ce prédateur géant est le poisson lune, le Mola mola
dont la proie préférée est la méduse.
Cet animal est rentré dans le Livre Guinness des records
comme le plus lourd des poissons osseux.
Il peut atteindre les 2000 kilos, juste en mangeant des méduses.
Je trouve là une très belle convergence cosmologique
que le Mola mola, dont le nom commun est le poisson lune --
trouve dans la méduse lune son mets préféré.
Alors c'est sympa de voir comment les deux lunes s'entendent à merveille,
même si l'une mange l'autre.
Voilà comment vous voyez habituellement le poisson lune,
voilà d'où vient son nom commun.
Ils adorent se dorer la pilule, et on peut le comprendre.
Ils sont là, tranquillement sur la surface de la mer
et on croit souvent qu'ils sont malades ou fainéants, mais c'est leur comportement habituel.
Ils bronzent tout simplement.
Leur autre nom, Mola mola, on pourrait croire que c'est du hawaïen,
cela veut dire meule en latin,
est du à leur forme bizarre et arrondie.
C'est comme si, en grandissant, on avait oublié leur queue
et c'est cela qui a attiré en premier mon attention,
cette forme bizarre.
Quand on regarde les requins, ils sont sveltes et élégants
quand on regarde les thons, ils sont comme des torpilles --
on voit clairement leurs aptitudes, ils bougent et ils sont forts
et maintenant regardez le poisson lune.
(Rires)
Puis c'est tellement élégant et mystérieux,
disons qu'il est plus intriguant que par exemple , un thon.
Donc, je me demandais, c'est quoi l'histoire de cet animal?
Bon, comme d'habitude en biologie, rien n'a de sens
sauf à la lumière de l'évolution.
Le Mola n'est pas une exception.
Ils sont apparus peu après la disparition des dinosaures,
il y a 65 millions d'années, quand les baleines avaient encore des jambes,
ils venaient d'un groupe rebelle de poissons-ballons --
je suis obligée de le raconter au style Kipling.
Bien sûr, l'évolution est en quelque sorte le produit du hasard, et vous savez,
il y a 55 millions d'années il y avait ce petit groupe de poissons globes rebelle
qui s'est dit, il y en a marre des récifs de corail --
on va en haute mer.
Après beaucoup de générations, beaucoup de changements et d'améliorations,
on a converti notre poisson globe en Mola.
Si vous donnez assez de temps à Mer Nature, vous obtenez ce résultat.
Peut être qu'ils ont l'air
un peu préhistorique ou pas finis, peut être raccourcis,
mais en fait,
ils rivalisent pour la première place du poisson le plus évolué de la mer,
juste là haut avec le poisson plat.
Tout a changé dans ce poisson.
En ce qui concerne les poissons --
les poissons sont apparus il y a 500 millions d'années, et les Molas sont plutôt récents,
ils ont tout juste 50 millions d'années --
et au fur et à mesure qu'ils ont évolués, leurs caractéristiques ancestrales ont disparues.
Ils débutent comme des petits œufs,
et ils sont encore dans le livre Guiness des records,
pour avoir le plus grand nombre d'œufs de tous les vertébrés de la planète.
Une seule femelle de 120 cm pond 300 millions d'œufs,
elle peut porter 300 millions d'œufs dans ses ovaires -- imaginez --
et elles atteignent parfois les 3 mètres, imaginez combien elle peut en avoir.
Ce petit œuf,
traverse cette phase épineuse de poisson porc-épic, réminiscence de ses origines,
et se développe, c'est leur petite adolescence.
Ils vont a l'école et ils deviennent des béhémoths solitaires à l'âge adulte.
Voilà un petit plongeur dans le coin.
Ils sont encore dans le livre Guiness des records,
pour être les champions de la croissance parmi les vertébrés.
De leur petite taille au moment de l'éclosion à la phase larve
jusqu'à ce qu'ils deviennent adultes, ils multiplient leur poids 600 millions de fois.
600 millions, imaginez que vous accouchez un petit bébé,
et il faut nourrir cette chose.
Ça veut dire que votre enfant, atteindrait le poids de six Titanics.
Je ne sais pas comment vous nourririez un enfant comme ça.
On ignore la vitesse à laquelle les Molas grandissent en liberté,
dans des études en captivité à l'Aquarium de Monterey Bay --
l'un des endroits qui en a en captivité --
il y en avait un qui avait pris 360 kilos en 14 mois.
Je dis, ça c'est un vrai américain.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Être solitaire de nos jours c'est quelque chose, notamment dans la mer
parce que l'école était jadis le salut des poissons,
mais aujourd'hui c'est du suicide.
Malheureusement les Molas, même s'ils ne vont plus à l'école,
sont pris dans des filets par accident.
Si on veut sauver le monde de la domination totale des méduses,
il faut connaitre les prédateurs des méduses --
comment ils vivent leurs vies, comme le Mola.
Or malheureusement, ils sont une partie importante de la capture accessoire en Californie --
jusqu'à 26 pour cent du filet.
En Méditerranée, dans les pêcheries d'espadons,
ils vont jusqu'à en représenter 90 pour cent.
Donc, il faut qu'on sache comment ils vivent leurs vies.
Comment faire ça?
Comment faire ça avec un animal présent dans très peu d'endroits dans le monde.
C'est une créature de haute mer, ne connait pas de frontières et ne s'approche pas de la terre.
Comment avoir une idée?
Comment convaincre une telle créature pour qu'elle te raconte ses secrets?
Heureusement, il y a une nouvelle technologie
qui est apparue très récemment,
c'est une aide précieuse pour avoir un aperçu de la vie des animaux en haute mer.
Vous la voyez ici ; cette petite étiquette là haut.
La petite étiquette peut enregistrer les températures, profondeurs ainsi que l'intensité de la lumière,
qui est en corrélation avec la date, et comme ça on peut les localiser.
On peut enregistrer des données pendant deux ans,
les garder dans cette étiquette et la libérer à un moment préprogrammé,
elle remonte à la surface, transfère les données dans sa totalité,
les envoie par satellite, qui les relaye directement à nos ordinateurs,
On récupère toutes ces données,
or on a juste du étiqueter l'animal, rentrer à la maison et s'asseoir dans nos bureaux.
Ce qui est génial avec le Mola
c'est comme ça qu'on met l'étiquette sur eux -- si vous regardez là haut --
c'est comme ça qu'on les suit, c'est là qu'on met l'étiquette.
C'est comme ça que ça se passe, c'est comme un parasite accroché au Mola.
Ils sont réputés pour porter beaucoup de parasites.
C'est des hôtels pour parasites, ses parasites aussi ont des parasites.
Je crois que Donne a écrit un poème sur ça.
Ils ont 40 types de parasites,
donc on s'est dit qu'un parasite de plus ne serais pas un grand problème.
Il se trouve qu'ils sont un très bon véhicule pour le transport d'équipement océanographique.
Ça n'a pas l'air de les déranger.
Qu'est ce qu'on essaie de savoir? On se focalise sur le Pacifique.
on étiquette près des côtes de Californie, de Taiwan et du Japon.
On s'intéresse à comment ces animaux utilisent les courants,
la température, la haute mer, pour vivre leurs vies.
On aimerait bien étiqueter à Monterey.
Monterey est l'un des rares endroits dans le monde où les Molas viennent en grand nombre.
Pas en cette période de l'année, plutôt vers Octobre.
On adorerait étiqueter ici, voilà une photo aérienne de Monterey --
mais malheureusement, les Molas finissent ici par avoir cet aspect.
En effet, une espèce locale aime les Molas mais pas de la bonne façon.
Le lion de mer de Californie prends les Molas dès qu'ils arrivent dans la baie,
arrachent leurs nageoires, et ils deviennent le dernier cri en frisbee style Mola,
et il les balance d'en arrière en avant.
Je n'exagère pas --
des fois ils ne les mangent même pas, c'est juste méchant.
Les locaux pensent que ce comportement est horrible,
c'est horrible de voir ça arriver chaque jour.
Les pauvres petits Molas qui arrivent, se faire déchiqueter...
Donc, on descends jusqu'à San Diego.
Ici il n'y a pas autant de lions de mer de Californie.
De plus les Molas, on peut les trouver facilement avec un avion d'observation ici,
et ils aiment trainer sous les algues.
Sous ces algues, et c'est pour ça que les Molas viennent ici
parce que ici c'est un spa pour les Molas.
Dès qu'ils s'installent sous les algues, le poisson qui fait l'exfoliation arrive.
Ils arrivent et et donnent au Molas --
vous pouvez voir qu'ils font cette drôle de pose qui dit,
je vous menace pas mais j'ai besoin d'un massage.
(Rire)
Ils sortent alors leurs nageoires et ils se mettent à l'aise,
et les poissons montent et nettoient, nettoient , nettoient --
parce que les Molas, vous savez, c'est un buffet gratuit pour les parasites.
C'est un endroit magnifique dans le sud
l'eau est plus chaude, et les Molas sont plutôt sympas là bas.
Je veux dire, quel autre poisson, en l'approchant,
vous dirait,"OK, gratte moi juste là."
On peut approcher les Molas dans l'eau, ils sont très gentils,
en les approchant gentiment, on peut les gratter et ils adorent ça.
On a aussi étiqueté une partie du Pacifique,
on est allé dans une autre partie du Pacifique,
et on a étiqueté à Taiwan et au Japon.
Dans ces pays, les Molas sont pris dans les filets qui longent leurs côtes.
On ne les rends pas comme capture accessoire, on les mange.
On nous a servi un menu composé de neuf plats à base de Mola après l'étiquetage.
Heureusement, pas celui qu'on avait étiqueté!
Tout, du rein aux testicules, en passant par la colonne vertébrale,
et par le muscle de la nageoire, je crois que ça veut dire pratiquement tout le poisson se mange.
Le plus dur lors de l'étiquetage est que
après avoir mis l'étiquette, il faut attendre des mois.
On se dit, j'espère que le poisson va bien,
j'espère qu'il va rester vivant
le temps que l'étiquette enregistre.
Chaque étiquette coûte 3500 dollars et pour le satellite il faut payer encore 500 dollars,
donc on se dit, j'espère que l'étiquette va bien.
L'attente est la partie la plus dure.
Je vais vous montrer nos dernières données.
Elles n'ont pas été encore publiées, c'est de l'info en exclusivité pour TED.
En vous les montrant, quand on les regarde,
on se demande, ces animaux, ont-ils traversé l'équateur?
Vont-ils d'une partie du Pacifique à l'autre?
On s'est rendu compte qu'ils sont plutôt casaniers.
Ce ne sont pas de grands migrants, voici leur itinéraire:
on a installé l'étiquette à Tokyo, et le Mola en un mois,
il a pris le courant de Kuroshio face aux côtes du Japon, et il s'est nourri là bas.
Après quatre mois, il est remonté vers le nord du Japon.
Voilà l'étendue de son domaine.
C'est important, s'il y a beaucoup de pêche,
la population ne peut pas se reconstituer.
Donc, c'est une donnée très importante.
C'est aussi très important de savoir que ce n'est pas un poisson fainéant.
Ils sont très travailleurs.
Voilà une journée dans la vie d'un Mola --
ils montent et descendent, montent et descendent,
montent et descendent, jusqu'à 40 fois par jour.
Le soleil se lève, vous le voyez en bleu, ils commencent leur plongée.
Plus le soleil brille, plus ils descendent.
Puis ils atteignent les 600 mètres et
la raison pour laquelle vous les voyez remonter à la surface est qu'il fait très froid en bas.
Ils doivent remonter, se réchauffer, prendre un peu d'énergie solaire,
et ils replongent dans les profondeurs, et remontent et descendent.
Ils trouvent une couche en bas, qui s'appelle la couche diffusante profonde
qui contient une grande variété de nourriture.
Plutôt que d'être simplement des fainéants,
ils sont vraiment travailleurs, ils mènent cette danse sauvage
entre la surface et le fond à différentes températures.
On voit le même modèle -- avec ces étiquettes
on voit un modèle similaire pour les espadons, les raies manta, les thons,
une vraie spectacle en trois dimensions.
Tout ça fait partie d'un programme beaucoup plus large appelé Recensement de la Vie Marine,
dans lequel on va étiqueter partout dans le monde
et le Mola en fait partie.
C' est fascinant -- on voyage, et vous savez
le plus intéressant des voyages est de rencontrer les locaux et
et de trouver les meilleurs endroits avec l'aide des locaux.
Maintenant, avec le Recensement de la Vie Marine, on pourra se mêler aux locaux
et explorer 90 pour cent de leur habitat, avec la connaissance local.
Il n'a jamais était aussi excitant ou important d'être un biologiste.
Ce qui nous amène au dernier point, le plus drôle de mon point de vue.
J'ai créé un site web car il y avait tellement de questions concernant les Molas et les poissons lunes.
Maintenant que ces questions ont leurs réponses,
je peux enfin remercier mes sponsors, comme National Geographic et Lindbergh.
Les gens peuvent écrire sur le site toute sorte
d'histoires sur ces animaux,
et on peuvent m'aider à obtenir des échantillons pour des analyses génétiques.
Ce qui me touche le plus est que tout le monde a
un amour partagé et un grand intérêt pour les océans.
J'ai reçu des rapports de la part des sœurs catholiques,
des rabbis juifs, des musulmans, des chrétiens, tout le monde y écrit,
unis par l'amour pour la vie.
Je ne pourrais pas le dire mieux que l'immortel chantre lui même :
"Un trait commun de la nature fait du monde entier une seule famille".
Vous voyez, c'est peut être juste un grand poisson vieux et bête mais
si il aide les peuples à agir ensemble, je pense définitivement que c'est le poisson de l'avenir.